bonjour régis merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors on a
vu ces deux attaques au drone imputé à
l'iran qui coïncide avec le deuxième
anniversaire de l'assassinât du général
souleimane et général iranien est ce que
ces deux affaires sont liées selon vous
il ya une forte symbolique puisque on
sait que racing souleymane sy avait été
assassiné lui par un drone armé en
compagnie d'ailleurs de comment abou
mehdi al mourr en dise qui était le
numéro 2 dh diaby l'energia buisson les
milices irakiennes pro iran donc les
deux avaient été assassinés par un drone
armé et 7 ce jour symbolique en ce jour
symbolique et bien les forces
américaines qui sont encore présentes en
petit nombre faut le préciser dans la
capitale irakienne ont été justement la
cible de ces drones qui ont pu est
comment dire après andy ou en tout cas
éliminé avant qu'ils ne commettent des
dégâts vous avez dit les troupes
américaines qui ont entamé un retrait le
9 décembre dernier il reste encore dans
la capitale pour quelles missions
exactement alors ces démissions dira
théorique finalement de demain tient
finalement d'une présence américaine
plus qu'autre chose on sait que depuis
le départ américain de l'afghanistan le
départ justement a sonné une sorte de
repli des américains dans le monde mais
les américains ne veulent pas quitter
l'irak pour le moment ni la syrie où il
faut le rappeler ils seront aussi
présentes sur tout en créant justement
les sens ce vide qu'on a pu voir
lorsqu'ils ont quitté l'afghanistan donc
il ya eu une sorte de prudence
théoriquement toutes les opérations les
missions de combat opérée par l'armée
américaine en irak sont aujourd'hui
terminés c'est ce n'est pas la vie en
tout cas de ceux qui manifestent et
qu'on voit à l'écran qui considère que
les américains continuent de les
surveiller il ya eu effectivement hier
pendant ces manifestations pour
commémorer justement la mort de rassam
suleimani des survols des commandes des
principaux cortèges de manifestants et
donc il y a au toujours une tension
autour de la présence de ces troupes
américaines les troupes américaines
existent sont aussi présentes autre part
dans le pays sur certaines bases elles
sont également en petit nombre et l ont
été
et mois dernier l'objet d' attaque à
deux tirs de roquettes sur ses bases ce
qui est devenu un classique alors tout
ça évidemment montre une certaine
confusion néanmoins il faut montrer
qu'il faut quand même préciser
aujourd'hui en irak il ya quand même des
signes je dirais d'une certain d'un
certain apaisement les dernières
élections législatives a donc
parlementaire le 10 octobre dernier ont
porté au pouvoir en fait le parti le
moktada al sadr se commande on se
cherche religieux chiites irakiens qui
autres autrefois c'était comment dire
d'illustrés dans son opposition se
souvient en 2004 2005 son armée du mahdi
avait été une véritable épine dans le
pied pour les forces d'occupation
américaines à l'époque il y avait
combattu les forces américaines mais
aujourd'hui moqtada al-sadr apparaît
comme un élément politique un petit peu
intermédiaire entre l'iran et les états
unis ayant toujours professé justement
d'ailleurs un nationalisme irakien assez
fort à la différence des ministres
hadjal s'habille très inféodés à l'iran
et puis des alliés de plus des états
unis qui sont encore au pouvoir donc il
ya une forme de commandes de clarté qui
commence un petit peu a émergé en irak
le même moktada al sadd arrière a reçu
les principaux chefs des à diaby pour
eux dans le but justement de procédé le
10 janvier prochain à la première
réunion du parlement et à la nomination
d'un nouveau premier ministre et d'un
nouveau président pour l'irak donc on
peut dire que peut-être que l'irak même
si 15 ans parce que ça faut le répéter
aussi nous sommes à 15 ans de la mort de
saddam hussein l'irak se cherche
toujours une direction l'irak est
toujours un pays fracturée mais sent
quand même que malgré ses 2 comment
puissance envahissante et rival qui se
sont livrés la guerre sur le territoire
de l'irak et bien l'irak tente
aujourd'hui de choisir une voie
intermédiaire à une voie plus nationale
on l'espère pourra porter ses fruits et
en tout cas mettre le pays dans une
bonne direction merci beaucoup régis le
sommier pour toutes ces précisions